what's going on reject nation so this
came out earlier today
pleasant surprise from the star wars
team ea star wars
star wars squadron hunted cg short
i'm always excited to check out the star
wars short films especially the ones
from the games because those tend to be
freaking awesome check out my new chairs
for gaming
oh it's a gaming chair this is going to
be an even better reaction
chair i can't mess around with it too
much or else the focus will get way out
of whack
let's do this
[Music]
the shaw
the station is lost
is a short film going to be from the
perspective of the imperials
i guess we're in for an anti-hero story
never give up never surrendered
now this is
you're doing so well
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
poor dude i've never felt bad
it's almost like there's a there's a
person under that helmet
oh poor guy it's okay man
oh
i love the mood i love the tension
oh this is so awesome i love seeing it
from this perspective i love it
it's like sharks in the water wow
[Music]
this is great this is wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing damn
get him kill that rebel scum
[Music]
wow kind of that uh jj abrams handheld
stuff going here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my goodness space junk
first thing i noticed man bun
[Music]
the true evil of the galaxy
i love how they play this music like
heroic music oh
oh hell yeah dude
god oh poor guy
and now you can die in peace
that was his arch nemesis
sandra bullock
this really does look like that scene
oh it's not over for him
yeah it's not
we did a reflection yeah yeah that was
great
that was awesome that was really awesome
that was legit
holy crap i'm really impressed with that
thank you
ilm i was really impressed with that
yeah i mean beyond just its
visual scope um which you know there's
plenty to talk about there
i love that this short film that they
unveiled the cinematic was from the
perspective of the imperials
because to a certain extent
there's a they're they they're they're
they're a lot of fine people
the imperial army i'm saying they're the
government they're the rebel alliance
so the rebels are in you know version
you know from depending on the
perspective they're the criminals
technically
yeah because they're rebelling yeah
yeah yeah so you see the perspective
switched and i thought yeah it's funny
to be
seeing this from what's usually the
enemy's side but i thought they made a
nicely compelling little short out of
this and also two was a rooting for him
yeah
you're rooting for him and then i liked
how they bring up the uh rebel guy
as this sort of he is sort of like the
side character and you're like okay are
we going to like switch perspectives no
this is just going to be our antagonist
like you know when the hitch uh psycho
the cop with the sunglasses
how that's kind of become a motif for
certain characters it kind of reminded
me of that guy the dude is just hunting
him down and they really capture
the guy on the rebel side of the x-wing
especially this is taking place after
the battle of endor
so the empire is crumbling right it's
actually a a great point in time
to take a chance in the audience to let
you look at it from the imperial side
because they're clearly
they've lost so to look at the rebel
side and see them as like kind of in
this bullying perspective you know
powers going down impedance scary sort
of yeah
foreboding imposing presence it was
funny to me too because you know this
is a cg short as the title of the video
points out it was a great reminder
of how just much everything in these
movies is cg because i was sitting there
in the first part going wow this looks
just as good as a star wars movie oh oh
that's right half the stuff inside
this star wars movie just is what we're
seeing here and so every time they
showed a human i was like oh that's
right we're not watching something
that's supposed to be
like directions so to speak well like
you pointed out what i loved
was how you say the rebel fighter was
like a shark
and i love that mood in that moment
because
i i don't recall seeing that in a star
wars film we've seen them where
they're like kind of hiding in that
scene where he's just hiding amongst the
rubble
and the debris yeah and trying to keep
himself
clouded in disguise as he's being hunted
in that very moment
i thought was so well captured like the
tension and the mood the suspense i love
all the mounting shots they did too yeah
it looked like you had an actual camera
mounted on stuff yeah well it's those
things that
add so much more credence to something
like this that's full-on animated you
know it makes it feel that much more
real and like the camera choices
throughout this like really made it feel
like a legit movie yeah and you can't do
one of these video game trailers
cinematics especially without saying the
thing
you gotta say which is way better than
the disney movies
you can't you can't do this without
saying that wasn't this the force
awakens
yeah what the hell hey man we'll just
give the next movie over to whoever made
this trailer and if they don't do a good
job then we'll kill them too
i mean they're gearing up there's got to
be a mandalorian trailer around the
corner too so they're trying to make
this star wars week
oh that was great love seeing the
imperials as people
and what did you guys think of this
trailer are you excited for the game
you're going to get it as a first week
of october right
october 2nd let us know your thoughts
down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
i want to shout out today a man named
mark leach
every time mark and i talk he kind of
has this apologetic
personality his personality that seems
like he doesn't feel
worthy to be chatting or something or
maybe i'm giving myself too much credit
or i'm going exactly off of what you're
saying to me buddy i love chatting with
you
you're a very humble guy to the point
where i'm i feel less than you when i
chat with you you work a job
that when you told me about it i was
like wow that is
way more important than anything i've
ever done in my entire life
if anyone should be humbled in someone's
presence it should be us
you're an amazing gentleman you're
incredibly supportive
you've got a interesting sense of humor
i love chatting with you every time man
so keep being you dude because you're a
great man and uh i'm very very fortunate
to know who you are
fun fact that wasn't chris evans's
genitals
it was working like leeches chris was
like hey man i need to borrow something
real quick
leak the leech